do you find that now that it's this
Blockbuster I mean probably the biggest
show Netflix has ever had right so
certainly one of them yeah top three
with stranger things stranger things and
wow good company yeah yes
um I would never never no no expect it
yeah we were like we're aiming for like
Umbrella Academy or like that would have
been so we love that show
but never expected it's insane yeah do
you feel like Netflix
obviously so supportive bought the show
from the first time around they they
said yes they were the only ones again
the second time around
do you feel like they're letting you do
your thing
for the most part they let us do our
thing the first season I mean so they
don't really they've been great I mean
they're involved and they give and I
said we want we want their notes and
their feedback yeah and you know and
they but they were they were always
behind it not too invasive no no no no
and it's it's again it's like we welcome
collaboration that helps and makes it
better so it's always like being open to
ideas and open to like outside eyes as
well like you need fresh eyes sometimes
you're in you know you're in the hole
it's like okay guys you've lost the
track on this one so but but it's and
they were incredibly supportive and had
to continue to be supportive and yeah
you know we were very lucky that that we
had an amazing marketing campaign and
not all shows get a marketing game yeah
I know it was and it was one of the few
Ali Feinstein Who's the who did this
campaign for them she's a Netflix it's
one of the few times where you feel like
the campaign actually captured the tone
of the show like The Campaign was funny
how many times have you watched
something where you're like going that
that wasn't at all
or a trail or is misleading you what you
see is what you get yeah like this is
the world we're going into yeah you're
right and we're invited you know very
early end up riding a lot of the copy
and stuff and then in the lines yeah but
but still that's great I mean I would
rather be invited it in and help and
actually make it sure that it does feel
like the show because it the same voices
are writing the ads as they are writing
the show so if you feel that and that
was an amazing experience yeah how soon
after did they say get back in the
writing room let's go it was
like it was like a couple weeks when the
couple of episodes aired well as you
know they dropped everything so oh yeah
it was like a couple that we had like
the first like because the data comes in
immediately so they know what's but they
know everything which is the amazing
thing they know when people stop
watching when they stop watching if they
watch the whole thing if they watch it
again yeah so
on this on the first Monday after the
after the drop we got we had an amazing
call with them saying Hell you know
they're like this thing's like of course
you know they they call and say you know
whatever that ad they put out like you
know how many 100 million minutes or
something and they're they're looking at
just like isn't this exciting and it's
like yeah but it's like telling me we
won a gazillion dollars like I don't
know what that but then when they put it
in context of where that falls with
their other shows I mean again they're
an incredible company when you see
I mean Wednesday was like the perfect
storm it was like they knew how to
Market it they were behind it 100 and
when you see the power of a streaming
service like Netflix it's like when when
they're behind something and it's just
like and when it and when something on
that show and then on that streaming
service works yeah and just it's like a
it's like a viral infection it just
takes off the word of mouth and it's a
global phenomenon overnight overnight
like you you think you guys like we were
again Smallville was an immediate hit
when it premiered on the WB but then it
you had a season and then you had a
summer of reruns and then it sort of was
a year later it was International and
and the second second season was bigger
than the first season of Smallville but
what was what was it was we're trying to
articulated because we're much more
relaxed about this right
the problem with Smallville is you're in
the room still writing a real episode
like six when that when the show
premiered and then you've got it's just
like the pressure to continue on a hit
show on network is so much greater
because you're actually in the you're
still making you're still in the Sausage
Factory and they're like they love it
keep making sausages they're still
battling yeah
and the train is going off the tracks as
you know like on the on the oh my God
just like holy crap